the historic west side could soon have
some resources to battle food and
security the neighborhood located
northwest of the spaghetti bowl could
soon have something called vertical
farming it's one of many concepts the
city is hoping will bring change to the
struggling neighborhood this aaron is
come back carla meads is proud to call
the historic west side her home for more
than 45 years but says the neighborhood
has deteriorated over time leaving
residents like her feeling abandoned
it's really dry this area here is like
more like drug activity the city of las
vegas is all hands on deck the city of
las vegas wants to turn things around
with the historic urban neighborhood
design redevelopment plan councilman
cedric creer says thanks to a half a
million dollar contribution from mgm
resorts the plan also aims to combat the
25 percent food insecurity impacting the
area with vertical farming imagine a
hydroponic growth facility inside of
these containers that's going to grow
about 3 million
pounds of food a year that we're going
to be able to get leafy greens we're
going to give back out to the community
through our
cooperative grocery facility that new
facility creer says will be operated by
a new non-profit snap residents will get
the food for free those living in the
neighborhood get a discount visitors pay
full price the project will also sell
the produce to mgm properties one of
several investments he says that will be
blooming in the next few years this
project is not the silver bullet right
but the combination of the hunter plan
on their planet action is that silver
bullet to revitalize the community meads
is hopeful this will be the change her
neighborhood needs it's greater i mean
it's showing a start of a new beginning
the councilman tells us the containers
have been ordered for the vertical
farming project and they plan on
launching it in november